[Music]
the French Basque Country is culturally
quite distinct from the rest of France
located in the southwest bordering Spain
the region is known among other things
for its ham which is salted and air
cured in an old tradition passed down
through generations of Basque farmers
there are several types of traditional
Basque Am this one called can tell is
marbled with fat and has a deep strong
fruity flavour it's distinct taste and
composition begin with a specific breed
of pig the Basque Country piebald
referring to the animal's skin this pig
breed is native to the Basque region
where livestock are raised on small
farms in the valleys of the Pyrenees
Mountains
unlike commercially farmed animals the
female pigs have small litters of six to
nine piglets which grow up roaming and
grazing along the vast mountain sides on
an average of two acres of land per 30
piglets as a result of this free-range
rearing the pigs grow more slowly and
become heavier than commercially farmed
pigs once the animals reach a weight of
about 330 pounds which usually takes a
year to 15 months they go to the
slaughterhouse each carcass is stamped
with an identification number
traditional ham is made from the hind
legs after tagging the leg a worker
places it in a machine which brands the
kanto assemble into the flesh
[Music]
then another worker spreads dry salt on
the exposed portion the salt comes from
Sayid of a yarn a saltwater spring in a
basin bordered by the Pyrenees Mountains
Theodore River and the Atlantic Ocean
[Music]
workers leave the salted ham in a cold
damp room for one day for every two
pounds typically about 15 days per ham
the salt preserves the meat next the ham
undergoes the first dry curing it hangs
on a stainless steel rack in a
temperature and humidity controlled room
for seven months when the ham comes out
of the room it has lost about 20% of its
original weight because most of the
moisture has evaporated
a worker brushes off the surface and
coats the exposed part of the ham with a
special grease that's made out of pigs
kidneys rice flour and water this grease
prevents the surface from drying out and
crusting during the second dry curing
[Music]
the ham now goes into a second drying
room which drives the ham in the open
air taking advantage of this particular
geographic location a warm southern wind
from Spain and humid air from the
Atlantic Ocean to the west blow into the
room through windows Nature does all the
work
humans merely regulate the air flow and
humidity by lifting or lowering the
blinds in this room the ham hangs from a
wooden rather than stainless steel rack
that's because the wood absorbs excess
humidity and transfers moisture to the
meat if the air gets too dry as the ham
dries its flavor concentrates the char
Kuti a an artisanal pork butcher
inspects every hand carefully
[Music]
the wind that dries the ham carries
pollen and other natural particles which
give this ham a distinct flavor and
fragrance
the secret is slow curing until the ham
reaches optimal maturity that takes
approximately one month per 2 pounds so
the ham remains in the second drying
room for more than a year when the cured
ham is ready
workers sprinkle it with espelette
pepper a mildly hot pepper from the
northern Basque Country
this gives the ham of fragrance that's
as appetizing as its taste